there's a party atmosphere in flinch on
the capital of Madeira the Portuguese
Island is celebrating something it has
plenty of flowers a highlight of the
celebration is a magnificent parade
always held three weeks after Easter
Roberto Rodriguez is taking part with
his dance group for a Samba born in
Portugal he lived in Switzerland for
many years now he's returned home it's
great to see how people are so happy to
see all the flowers the dancing our
costumes it's wonderful to take party
the flower festival was the main topic
of conversation in Funchal four weeks
before the parade floral carpets have
been spread out on the main promenade
and flowers handed out to visitors
Roberto and his team start preparing for
the parade in early April it's taken
quite a bit of effort
[Music]
it's difficult to coordinate all the
people the whole team that's here we
work under time pressure of course to
get everything done everything has to be
ready tomorrow is not just the float
where you also have to coordinate 130
people the countdown is on with one day
to go floats and marchers have to be
transformed into bouquets of flowers
within a single day to make sure the
blossoms stay fresh
the hats made with orchids and thorium's
and Proteus help people get into the
party mood before the parade kicks off
designer Dena Trinidad a is responsible
for the costumes and floral accessories
she emphasizes color and authenticity
from here and we use this weaker work
this is made here in Madeira so it's
part from our handmade art craft it's
really fun because it's a flower
festival and do you live in an island
full of color full of nature and you
have to project a word with it and that
gets really interesting because it's
something that you love so it always got
that little touch
Madera is called the island of flowers
they flourish in the subtropical climate
even on rocky or volcanic ground so it's
the ideal place to celebrate an annual
festival of flowers
[Music]
the director of tourism couldn't agree
more a small flower festival started
with an exhibition that's over 60 years
old about 63 and then about 30 years ago
we started with the parade as it is with
groups involved which has been growing
year by year and this is one of the
biggest in numbers 1,500 people starting
with little ones from four year olds
it's Sunday afternoon and in 15 minutes
the parade will begin Roberto and his
club were up until 2:00 in the morning
putting together and decorating their
float now it's ready to move out and the
club members pose for tourists Roberto
can feel the adrenalin rising I'm really
excited
that's completely normal when you
organize all the people and everything
else here I'm sure it'll be a great show
the crowd of about 100,000 spectators
don't mind a light drizzle many of them
booked and paid for their seats months
in advance so they could celebrate the
advent of spring with the Islanders the
festival draws people from all across
Europe
[Music]
we've been to Madera several times and
always wanted to see the parade we came
especially to see it I'm coming from
Rome this is a beautiful flower festival
really we don't have these like this in
Italy I'm from Holland and I like the
Paris very well because in Holland we
also have flowers with so much floral
spectacle spring can't be anything but
gorgeous and the roboto is certain he'll
be taking part again next year
[Music]